are you like a cow or a Dalmatian I am
the spot don't don't do that
[Music]
miles wanna get out of here can this day
get any weirder I guess it can
stop him there's nowhere to run
my bad everybody there was somewhere to
run Spider-Man across the spider verse
miles win wanna get out of here wait
wait there's an elite Society with
Spider-Man oh no way all of us are do I
uh have web on my face what's the deal
what's the guy I gotta do to join this
spider team you don't belong out there
don't even get me started on Doctor
Strange and a little nerd back on Earth
1999.99 what Spider-Man across the
spider verse did this day get any
weirder
I guess it can exclusively in cinemas
coming soon
being Spider-Man is a sacrifice you have
a choice between saving one person and
saving an entire world I
forever foreign
across the spider verse exclusively in
cinemas coming soon